[Music]
we're all crazy about Disney Princesses
everyone has their favorites and we love
seeing them reimagined as bad girls
real-life teenagers and even animals but
what if our favorite t-ara ladies were
transformed into handsome Prince's don't
forget to hit that subscribe button and
give this video a big thumbs up now
let's talk about Disney Princesses as
Disney princes so this is what a party
looks like Elsa frozen hit the big
screen and instantly became a classic
the whole world has caught the frozen
bug and we can't let it go
fans love the movie so much that they
spend hours creating art inspired by the
characters there are tons of images of
Elsa reimagined as a Snow King artist
Julia J m15 from tumblr created this fun
version of the beloved princess can you
get over those perfect blue eyes
that gorgeous plot them hair what really
grabbed our eye are the gorgeous suits
inspire by Elsa's gowns the Wardrobe in
these drawings perfectly captures the
style of the characters while playing up
their new gender it's not easy to turn a
sparkling ballgown into a perfectly
tailored suit but this artist totally
nails it Pocahontas Pocahontas is a
strong and brave princess she's a fierce
person imagine that incredible
personality in a hardened warriors body
Canadian artist Akemi Chan did and the
results are breathtaking we've loved
that tsukimi kept the characters long
hair the shaped sides of that undercut
would look just as great on the female
version of the character too the artist
also kept the beautiful shell necklace
we loved seeing a strong male character
with gorgeous accessories and a fierce
look Prince Pocahontas is spot-on he
still loves animals and is drawn with
his best friend split and Miko just like
his female counterpart he's strong
courageous and compassionate Jasmine
gender swapping Disney Princesses is a
hugely popular theme there does seem to
be a lot of similarities between styles
many princesses reimagined as princes
are drawn as delicate add raja'na smen
with clean shaven faces that's what
makes this version of jasmine so amazing
here we see the elegant princess as a
rugged enhanced
man who love the beard princesses redrew
as men rarely sport facial hair either
this unique take on the character is one
of the best ginger swaps we've ever seen
even Raja gets a fierce makeover male
Jasmine's characteristic fashion
translates well to we love the teal
jumpsuit deep cut v-neck and gold boots
men like to be gorgeous - after all
Tinkerbell artist Marian who is also
known online as galaxy speaking on
tumblr has gender swap - most of the
characters from Peter Pan her spunky
girl character Pat chirpin is just as
mischievous as the original character
she's reimagined Captain Hook's the
darling children and Smee but our
favorite is Tinkerbell her version of
the fairy is edgy tattooed and tough
we're loving the slightly rough looking
wings and moody expressions this version
of the character captures Tinker Bell's
tough attitude perfectly all of the
ethereal beauty is still there but in a
really masculine package Tinker Bell
makes a really fierce looking guy we
love how well the artist captures the
characters attitude in one facial
expression Merida
Merida is one of the most formidable
Disney characters ever written she's
courageous a skilled Archer and
obviously brave the character is
larger-than-life and unafraid to face
any challenge artists may be Chan
reimagines Merida as a tall rugged
Prince the character looks just as
capable of facing a bear we can't help
but wonder if Merida would have been
encouraged in her archery if she had
been a boy would she have been even more
skilled or is her talent so natural that
encouragement wouldn't make much a
difference either way this kilted
version looks just as fierce as his
female counterpart snow white snow white
is the original Disney Princess she
launched the brand and set the stage for
full-length animated movies to become a
family staple the character is beloved
and known for her beauty even reimagined
as a man Snow White is still the fairest
in the land the costuming in this
reimagining is spot-on Snow White's
iconic gown becomes the perfect suit for
a fair-skinned friends he's still
surrounded by animals and as gentle as
the female character now we want to see
the dwarves as when
two prints no white is spot on in this
swap Cinderella Cinderella is the story
of a girl down on her luck she loses her
father and finds herself surrounded by
evil stepsisters she's forced to clean
and treated as a servant she gets her
happy ending when a prince falls in love
with her and whisks her away to a life
of luxury artist jazz demo from
deviantART imagines the story a bit
differently this artist has rejoined the
hard-working girl as an industrious
young man we loved his whistle games as
he leans on his broom his apron and
capri look right at home in a kitchen
but his beautiful blue suit is ready for
even the fanciest royal ball this Prince
is sure to win hearts anywhere he goes
Belle Beauty and the Beast is one of the
most well known Prince's stories in the
Disney library bookish Belle is clever
kind and brave artists have reimagined
her in all kinds of ways we can't get
enough of this version of the character
Belle's famous brown hair and stunning
gold ballgown translate perfectly as a
prince the character dons a stunning
gold suit that rivals the iconic gown
Belle's beautiful hair becomes a
gorgeous short style this version of
Belle is just as elegant and poised we'd
love to see a stunning female beast to
dance with this handsome prince Ariel
who doesn't love Ariel the feisty
redhead mermaid showed the world that
anything was possible and love could
cross any obstacle artists tsukimi chin
reimagines this mischievous mer person
as a handsome young Merman the
characters iconic red hair is still
there just shorter we love that Sookie
me included a purple clamshell necklace
as a nod to Ariel stop the cherry on top
of this piece is cute girly flounder
we've never seen such perfect lashes on
a fish every Disney Prince should get an
animal sidekick Ariel is just as
beautiful and otherworldly imagined as a
man this Disney Prince is short to win
over anyone princesses or princes we
hope you loved seeing these Disney
treasures reimagined we'll see you next
time
[Music]